charlie où est mon argent mon pote j'ai
ton argent c'est prêt je vais bien
mais charlie tu perds ta ceinture
charlie était le meilleur prétendant numéro deux
au monde
alors le jeu de combat a changé
je viens avec toi non tu n'es pas
soit je viens avec toi, soit tu
pêches tes clés dans les égouts oh mon
dieu c'était proche whoa têtu
ce n'est pas un jeu vidéo c'est pour de vrai
gagnons de l'argent
j'ai juste besoin d'un petit
prêt autant  comme je t'aime mec
tu es un mauvais pari frère
abandonne charlie
tu n'as plus rien
que cherchons-nous tout ce que je pourrais
utiliser pour assembler un robot de combat
je pense qu'il y a un robot entier là-dedans
je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel  avant de
pouvoir le combattre, c'est un
robot d'entraînement conçu pour prendre beaucoup de coups mais
ne infligeant jamais de vraie punition,
son nom est Adam,
faites-lui un combat,
vous savez que vous le ramenez à la maison en
morceaux,
il est plus petit et plus faible, il est  va se
faire botter le cul
j'ai besoin que tu t'apprennes dans une boîte tu
rigoles  en moi tu connais ce jeu de combat à l'
intérieur et à l'extérieur il a besoin de tes mouvements tes
commandes je ne peux pas je ne peux pas oui tu peux
et je sais que j'ai fait toutes sortes de torts
par ce gamin
j'aime juste faire une chose bien
je  J'essaie de voir un meilleur côté de toi
ici charlie ce n'est pas facile
nous ne pouvons pas gagner pouvons-nous
nous verrons